[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to play for
all it's Friday we made it to the end of
the week and we have a very special
guest today my good friend Naomi Kyle
hey Naomi
chasity thanks for having me I'm
starting here and we've got Han Larry on
deck to a rocket League expert here at
GameSpot how many times have you
purchased this game mr. Rob handler oh
boy I think I think when it came on a PC
it was like a bundle so you could get
like four codes so for their Xbox switch
so what seven yeah acting spot Naomi
loves rocket League she suggested this
camp we're not dead here he wants to
play it and she's got like a lot cool
custom cars too so they're doing a
charity stream today for two hours with
Naomi and we've got some cool stretch
goals so Naomi tell them what you're
gonna do for the stretch goals okay so I
actually did this last time on another
charity stream but I am going to face
paint so we're gonna put out some ideas
we want chat to be involved but we want
to do pretty much anything that's like
you know fun like puppies rainbows
Batman logos whatever so I've got my
paint here and a cup of water and some
napkins and so if you guys decide once
we reach our stretch goals we'll decide
what I get to paint and I have like you
know my cheek I'm gonna paint one thing
and then we'll hopefully reach the other
goals and I'll just like gradually keep
adding stuff like you know face painting
might and my face with a bunch of
different characters should be fun it
will be fun and in a less artistic way
Rob's got some markers that he got at
the local CVS
I mean markers but we can make rough
actually so yeah this was gonna be a
little bit of a surprise but and maybe
we can kind of on the fly makeshift
a separate stretch goal but I will match
your drawing and try to do it myself
with no fear
this is kind of where I was at
we could tack on I could just do it
automatically or we can tack on another
stretch goal I don't know up to you
chassis I guess so in order to get these
fun things happening you need to donate
so please help us raise money for black
lives matter and cope in nineteen
directly relief the links are in the
description Ritchie's going to drop them
in the chat to I'll be in the chat
dropping in links when I can and I'll be
monitoring when you guys donate to
either one of those causes and so after
the very first donation that we get you
get to pick Naomi's car so I'm waiting
for the first donation to happen and
then you can see which car name is gonna
use in the first match of rocket League
and then after that we will do stretch
goals so the first stretch goal to get
the first Naomi face painting session is
be hit I'm gonna say let's let's be
let's be fair what do you think 150 or
200 Naomi hmm let's go 200 okay so now
you will start face painting at $200 so
keep that in mind let's raise some money
let's do this for a good cause and you
owe me let's do a little fashion car
show
let's Fashion Show Fashion Show at work
oh my god yes please keep referencing me
of it throughout all this okay so and
just to preface this I took a lot of
time to set these up these are all my
presets
they're all themed in this special way
so as you can see right now you're
looking at the monster pride I've named
them all according to their themes and
so this is my monster prize it does
shoot rainbows so you can be rest
assured that that's good we have here at
the electric which this is oh I was
inspired by the Hat I love the witch hat
I think it's cute so there you go that's
and I really I only have one or have
like maybe one other paint job that is
you know animated so I'm you're gonna
see that one a lot throughout my
characters my little cars so this is the
John Candy
so Canadian flag naturally he's a comic
so it's got the comic kind of decal on
there and I'm not exactly sure but I
just liked that
siren thing on top of there this is
killer cat killer cat
who's you know a DJ and he likes to race
around and you know cause fireworks and
bombs to go off and he's awesome that's
killer cat we got the Rick whoo which of
course is inspired by Rick and Morty the
troll this is so if we look on the back
side here you probably can't see it but
that that little smiley face flag oh
yeah he's always trolling people when
he's a badass and then here we got the
boho this is um this is because I've
been into like interior decorating I
mean we're all cooped up in her houses
so I'm like let me try to refresh stuff
so I've been really into the boho style
and I figured I'd make a car based on
that so you got of course your little
succulents on top and a tulip
this is trash okay this is everything I
could find that was the ugliest that I
hated looking at this is the trash car
so yeah we could definitely I haven't
played with this one yet so let's see
how that goes I know that car it smells
gnarly right it's uh it's that's
supposed it's um it's emulating that
that's the goal and then this is the
rock and a B based based on Downton
Abbey but in the car um top hat and a
brown color and obviously the old timey
vehicle model and when we have oh this
one this is the Barbie girl you know
just pink and bubbly and I recently sang
that song for a dream so I figured I'd
make a Barbie girl car and I like bright
colors I'm so inspired by the bright
colors that I had and we're back to
Monster pride let's love it I'm gonna
drop those names in the chat and on
YouTube so if the first donation then
please pick the car with your donation
yes perfect and I would got that in the
twitch chat as well all right so let's
let's get into the game guys let's do it
what's doing do it should we do a little
warm-up with some some casual play yeah
definitely I've been trying to practice
my shots in my aerial shots I'm terrible
but uh I keep trying to improve my game
so and you're the expert so I'm hoping
you're gonna help me with some tips
that's I play the game a lot but yeah
III feel like my aerial game is okay
like maybe like three out of ten shots
like I can make with the really good
shots the rest is garbage I play online
or what are we doing oh you already got
us in again okay cool I guess we won
what congratulations you did it failed
yay we want her first magic so
successful oh you're not in this I guess
I got yeah I was I was still in the
lobby so I wasn't sure if you'd started
Oh Naomi mary says hello she's in the
twitch jet you're so far away now I
missed you we all miss Mary in the
twitch chat too so if you are the first
donation please pick a car that you want
Naomi to use no me you want to quit it
says you're in a game right now yeah I
did I did ready myself but oh I can't
leave the match says all right you can't
use a match yes it's for some reason not
letting me and nothing's kind of
starting let's hope rocket leagues not
having any issues so we're okay no I can
leave the match because we start with a
match okay I got it
yeah all right if it was ranked it gets
a little more aggressive I think you get
banned for five minutes if we did that
but oh
casual no one no one gives it's casual
we're keeping it cash just like no if
you just joined us the donation links
are in the description also being
dropped in chat on YouTube by Ritchie so
thanks for that so when we get the first
donation you get to pick Naomi's car for
the next match and then we've got
stretch goals wearing a Oh me is going
to do some face painting later so be
sure to donate and help us out and raise
money for a good cause
Coliseum I am down I love it alright I
think we have a donation
yeah yeah go for it so we have I'm
checking on both because I don't want to
miss anyone okay we have one for black
lives matter from Nawaz Iqbal $10 thank
you so much for donating to black lives
matter if you are in the chat please let
us know what car you pick otherwise
we're gonna have the chat pick for you
because there wasn't a note on the
donation but if you're in the chat let
you know and you get to pick the book
you okay there I'm fine and have my
seatbelt on oh [ __ ] oh no okay I so glad
you you went over there
oh here we go yep set it up for you yeah
close oh I didn't have enough boost I
almost was able to do an aerial shot but
looks like we're up against a good group
of people here no I'm not letting you
get this let's play aggressive I was so
scared that wasn't going in
look at that whew yeah no that was uh
that was close there that's good you
gonna go for it okay
you got all blue stuff yeah
took it from him set it up oh he set it
up for me thanks bro
oh no see I wasn't in position to do
that
yes you got this man
shooting rainbows
alright okay it's on our side that's
good for yep yep oh shoot I wasn't ready
that was that was a tough one I kind of
know it was good it was good
definitely keep letting me know when you
have it set up almost block that for you
wow thanks oh my golly caption it is
right there
ha I got them out of the way it's yours
take a ticket okay I'm coming I'm gonna
be on top of this one for you yeah this
back way here whoops I'm in Reverse
let's go back then oh nice save those
good thanks oh this is it do it now it's
Alex week 55 is real pissed I'm gonna go
for it oh yeah go oh they bounced it
back oh nice I don't know what that did
good everyone got some air yeah those
good uh I'm there you go they're playing
dirty they're trying to push me out of
the way and Wow that deserves a WoW yeah
I like that imagine Alex screaming right
now ha ha ha I want that one no he was
ready nice yes yes
he is screaming is he okay oh he's gone
he's not in the game anymore or frozen
or something I don't know what he was
doing I don't have any boost okay let's
go it's ours yours
swifty kill be killed yeah red flag got
blowed up
she had a new mode yes like foul red
flied okay
I'm setting it up kind of sorted no
there yes oh oh I was going too fast
okay let's go get that I don't have any
more boost he got mine okay yay yay
don't worry Sebastian I was also never
good at rocket League replay where's the
replay I'm sorry for your eardrums I'm
gonna try to keep it no you're good
screaming to a minimum there it is Oh
I'm gonna write for whoo all right so we
have a car change because we had our
first donation yeah what's the pic nawaz
got to pick and he picked the John Candy
the John Candy I'm choice fine fine I
just got an Alpine hat so we're
switching to the John Candy thank you
for the first donation Elena and exit
than that right sorry about that
yeah I think I read it up for next match
but let me leave it can we leave it is
that what say again
the car here uh I should have told you
know Naomi I went back to the main menu
I did too so what I was saying was I
accidentally hit ready up for the next
one so we're back I'm in the garage now
and selecting the John Candy let's do it
I love the good skin it's like a comic
book yeah that's why I went with it very
good if you want to be cool like Nawaz
and help us raise money those donation
links are in the description Ritchie's
dropping them in chat I'll drop them in
there too and we've got stretch goals so
when we hit 200 dollars during the
stream Naomi's gonna do some fun face
painting and we're all get to vote on
what she's going to paint on her face
and Rob's gonna try to copy it too so
please make that happen we need washable
markers guys I feel like it would have
been more of an incentive if you had
bought permanent markers but I know I
thought about it yeah
I stood there I mean I asked the the
clerk oh but you have any face paint
okay that's fine it also is the world's
most washable so it's kind of the
opposite I guess world's most washable
apparently are we ready for some
competitive play yeah let's do it
we won that so easily yeah so many goals
let's do it I'm glad I just got one goal
like that was my home for today more -
yeah I will
that's the plan and if you've got any
questions for Naomi drop them in the
chat and I'll ask for you but I have got
question with my own Naomi what game are
you looking forward to next gosh besides
everything that got delayed okay such a
good dose of Tsushima go sabina
definitely on my list obviously
cyberpunk my sure did I'm excited
looking great yep I freaking love it I
love what they're doing I love how
they're doing all the presentations and
start your Barry Jerry the Barry Barry
all right you very much don't like Jerry
all right that's it that's it here we go
no no I got to I got too excited I
that's what happens I'm like I'm gonna
save this and then I just I jumped the
gun I don't know that's like all right
go for uh all right yeah yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna stay here back here cuz I
think we need some some defense oh oh
I'm not quite there but that's okay
no okay these guys are really good I
think we made a mistake going into
competitive life possibly I have to
produce we can always do more practice
we can back out in practice I mean
what's what's rocket League without some
really hate-filled losses oh I'm so
nervous I'm just gonna try to stay in a
position where I can defend oh okay you
got it you got it you got it got it
getting more boost I got so close to him
that
come bring it back bring it back killed
like dad I don't know what I'm doing
right now freak out Iida saved the same
thing I think he's gonna hit it and I
like I'm all prematurely hit I'm just
premature on the hips Oh No instant oh
the old the old swing shot right I was I
was helping you with some momentum there
okay all right Jerry the Barry you're
knocking this one to get you got it it's
yours
do you like I sort of helped you a
little bit
as long as I'm helpful come on yeah yeah
good job
Rob you got a gradation from passion
Sebastian Ramsey asks what's your
favorite car so I actually really only
play on ps4 and I have a like forget
what rarity it is but it's a Takumi rx I
believe and I have never changed
distance Oh too much bill trying to get
better at aerial stuff but that was on
me I gave it to him skip it skip it
what games are you guys looking forward
to UM cyberpunk for sure doesn't suit
you
peeper Mario I've never played a Paper
Mario but I'm definitely playing that it
looks so good
yeah I think I'm definitely gonna play
Marvel's Avengers just cuz I love the
ending and I'm gonna see he helped he
helped us with that one did you see he
totally did it
did you top it ready before I went in Oh
Oh death gang a little aggressively
sherry the Barry Jerry the Barry helped
you yeah I think he's oh wait or was
that no that was our oh that was that
was definitely then yeah man now
we just need one more goal we got this
might save money I'd screw that up so
headphones I'm gonna try to like scream
like get away from the mic a bit I just
don't have the the new Elgato mic that
apparently helps in thinking a little
bit yeah oh okay let's all calm down
friends calm yourselves okay this is
ours we can do this
oh that's geri-beri man he is not our
friend I hate him
okay get back in order I Jerry the berry
all right good
just an over to the left I could have
stopped that but I wasn't ready okay go
for it yeah you want it okay I'm coming
oh damn it I got a shoulder shot
oh yeah oh man they're good at defending
their goal something I'm not good at it
he's that
dude no way look at them oh I was going
to Jerry is unstoppable Mary we got a
$25 donation from our very own Ritchie
he's recognized you would like to
request the trash car next time yes away
from the mic Naomi away from the mic oh
shoot okay let's do this it's yours
good job I guess you're you're just you
know keeping the ball away from them and
that's that's good enough okay and you
crushed it I was totally my intention
Jess didn't know what to do with it
we're putting that we're putting up a
good fight but we don't have much time
left
yeah it's not looking great but that's
okay it's their first competitive match
it is and they're just really good so so
I say let's just not be oh okay not on
goal shot a go oh are you were still
miss there's a rocket League it's hard
I run should turn down their volume to
like 25% Oh are we Pekin Oh
oh I don't know if we are but I I am
definitely just being aware and I'm on I
can't get my car up okay there you it
sounds fine to me
good I could yeah
yeah let's do it g-g-gee Jerry Jerry
so we're gonna switch to the trash car
next and just a reminder we are
collecting donations raising money for
black lives matter and Cove in nineteen
relief so those links are in the
description so help us reach our stretch
goals so we can do some face painting
later and thank you to those who have
already donated so let us know if you
have any questions for Naomi or for Rob
or for me and yeah we're gonna keep this
going for you wow it's beautiful it is
the beauty I think honestly is the most
disgusting part is that sandwich I hate
that so much it's not even a sandwich
it's literally just an old piece of
bread like a slice of bread it's kind of
I think it's got like like the peanut
butter marshmallow in it that's that's
me at least thinking I don't know it's
got something inside it peanut butter
okay I will take it maybe it's like a
rotten fresh french toast or something
yeah or it's just rotting or just
rotting I'm ready when you are
party let's go for it yeah that car
smells a good way it's C that's exactly
what I wanted the reaction I was like
how gross can I make this garlic alright
lightning yeah it's got a am i
pronouncing right Toshima bud yeah we're
just missing the yellow leaves
that's so ass oh boy all right dark pole
yo yo chill chill let's take it easy
guys
this is a friendly match we're if I
could just get closer to the ball let's
try to do that look at them climbing up
and make it what you can't do that
they're animals rats we need your help
on this one all right oh yeah you're
saving us we got a donation from send
you're busy man who donated $20 to
direct relief and said Naomi used the
DeLorean and get back in time might have
to do another preset for that one okay
I'm so disappointed I had the shot it
was a shot I was clean in my sights and
I messed it up I don't know where I
almost was there it's all good
this is practice this is practice this
is practice all right yeah you go oh
yeah no what was the Hat I try to do
like a dumb speed boost but new
ah what's this guy's name
carve G cars oh no I totally screw that
up that's told me that was told me Oh
skip it it's G curve and I'll go for it
Oh keep wanting it man what are they
doing to be this good probably
yeah I'd say they've probably played
like 700 hours of this game result right
how many hours have you played I don't
know
countless wood on what platform yes for
ps4 yeah that's the only way yeah rather
asking what's the goal to get you to
draw on your face or are you gonna do it
when Naomi does it I'm anything I think
we should just do it when would I do it
yeah okay and that means you know hit
the stretch goals guys yeah so when we
hit 200 it's gonna be both Naomi and Rob
and they're both gonna do it so Naomi's
gonna do hers then Rob's gonna try to
copy it
yeah on his own face without a mirror
are you gonna drive oh no mom I'm pretty
good but I'm not good at drawing on my
face yeah it's thinking I'm gonna do
without a mirror
I've been married here keeps a few loves
this trash car yeah it's the best
how do you get down from like being
thrown into the air quickly is there a
way to do that
no what's you like rocket what's you
like it's down I guess but like yeah
it's that's a bummer first she's gonna
wait for the first come on oh my god you
are saving us for us
am I glad to be on your team I mean
while you're like Naomi stop slacking
please know the game with us I'll try to
get better at that oh my
blew up the other dude we're good
awesome Bradley asked yeah I feel I did
I've been playing a little bit of it
Thanks so not enough I feel like I
should play more I mostly to be honest
been playing Animal Crossing and come on
yeah right mmm that was also they're so
random like I just I just really stomped
the stalks mean something am I like oh
yeah it's Animal Crossing railroad
crossing yeah how it's just a it's a
play on the stock market for arena
yeah my slow to die curry we did it good
job good job good teamwork teamwork okay
I'm gonna go whew go for it
y'all go do it oh I freakin mess it up
for you no no it's fine you have more
speed yeah I had speed I had but I
didn't have the aim
yeah go for it
okay we stop time to get this this is
this is ours this is not over
nope it's not over oh oh sure eight oh I
don't know it's bad he'll get it no he
won't
no I know I'm here oh okay oh that's a
sec okay waiting for it
oh this is not good I don't it's too
high it was a tall order I screwed that
up to you at least at least you're
getting hits on them all that's like oh
good job good job you're holding the
ball
oh we're got blown up they killed you
yeah they killed a trash bag wow those
[ __ ] matter know how stinky
our car wash
Jesus smells like farts yes girl I think
you really psyched him out here I got
lucky there but worse I think those
donations the donation links are in this
the description below and we are working
at first two hundred dollars this stream
so that Naomi will do some fun face
painting and Rob will copier with some
markers to make that happen
no I got it in the chat yeah just give
me your questions for Naomi I'm gonna go
through some of the last few what are
all of you excited for ps5 or xbox
series X
I'm I've gotten every single PlayStation
so I am definitely getting a ps5 and
that's oh I want to play spider-man
Miles Morales yes I'm in the same boat
where I used my xbox usually for like
all-around entertainment like media
center and then the PS 5 just has like
these really great games that I really
loved playing on the ps4 like the sequel
like you said for spider-man and alright
you go we're done
okay oh yeah so I'm in this I'm going
I'm probably to buy the place that
you're 5 first and then yeah
so we're all in agreeance psi I think so
across the board here I mean are we
gonna get DCC asked me did chess to get
that life-sized side up yet i
pre-ordered it and it says it's gonna
arrive in late 2020 so I'm really
important when that happens and I told
my roommate tomorrow's my room and I was
like hey we have a third roommate living
in this fall I just want to let you know
I saw a picture the left side side up so
we're both very jaded but for now I've
got this guy and he's not bad
it's such a good collection of stuff
back there thank you you're very cute
they bring me joy if you get like a
screenshot of it so I can zoom it it's
my department of morale man but you've
been deep you've got a pop you mean a
live puppy hello a real big Pokemon guys
follow me oh man social you probably
already saw that she's got the cutest
little puppy in the whole world named
Odin adorable and he likes to eat socks
[Laughter]
be pretty much yeah if you give him
something he'll probably try to eat it
though he's pizza he eats everything
he just needs everything I need to be
like you eat this nothing Oh Richie said
I believe in you trash car no anything
right now is everyone like just off
their game what's going on
five five like we need some I think
they're playing the game where they just
don't want us to score at all oh my god
yeah I know what you heard no I and it
wrong or something
I'm side by the way I'm being like
really critical of myself so I can learn
like I'm trying to analyze and dissect
what where I'm where I need improvement
you know reactants I take this very
store tiny still in overtime oh that's a
good one I didn't hate what I'm out of
boost its thirst that is thirst
Oh Rob question you know is there gonna
be any more vile villager videos that's
hard it was um unfortunately we don't
think so he said the last one had him in
stitches I know that was a bummer that
was cut in a way uh grand finale it was
a it was a good finale but I we talked
about it like it was one of the things
where we felt like we went all out and
uh we were hoping for a bigger reception
but we cannot ran out of ideas after
that maybe with some updates wait
there's more yeah so are we changing the
car or anything like that
I'm gonna ask the last request was for a
DeLorean I don't know if you could just
pick one do you nation for kovin
nineteen relief direct relief we've got
five dollars from anonymous so thank you
so much thank you thank you for your
donation every every dollar counts um so
DeLorean I don't think I even modeled a
DeLorean let's do the killer cat let's
go to Yale yeah let's go
yeah that's exactly what it sounds like
in my mind it just likes blowing stuff
up and yeah damn it I was a ticking time
bomb look at this that's what that's a
nice looking car I think I love the
tires ghostrider so I love it I love
anything that's animated and really
bright and shiny makes me feel cool oh
you actually selected it's funny your
your car models the same as my boho car
but different you know flag it all yeah
yeah but same decal and same car model
that's funny mm-hmm you know great minds
think alike absolutely absolutely
yeah I like the UM you know one I like a
lot is the Dominus it's like kind of
like the I want to say like Charger
Mustang looking car yeah yeah uh just I
just love this game so cool yeah thank
you all and in joining us Naomi's here
helping us out raising money for Kobe 19
relief and black lives matters so thank
you so much for being here and yeah
she's a guest today she didn't join
GameSpot there were a couple questions
here and we are working towards our
stretch goal here for $200 and then we
will do some face painting and Rob will
try to copy her with markers on his own
face so let's get there we've got one
hundred and forty dollars left to reach
our goal so thank you to those who have
already been donating and if you want to
donate those donation links are in the
description below and Ritchie's dropping
them in the check
mrh gaming says naomi is the greatest
streamer ever thank you
yeah I've been streaming a lot I'm
obviously the latter what came out last
was - that was the other game I was like
what have I been playing like oh yeah
it's been a mix of Animal Crossing
laughs - and then recently finally
finished Luigi's Mansion 3 which I
didn't stream but I love that game glad
I finished it because the endings so
it's like like it's cute sateen or a
happy sad thing damn it I did my dad
growing up was always trying to not
swear I got only heard him swear once
all right well like on attention
unintentionally like yeah but he would
always go rats
try but the one time he we ever as kids
heard him swear he said the f-word was
with your road trip in Arizona and my
brother slammed the sliding van door on
his hand oh and and and I had this child
safety lock so it locked on the outside
and so there was a period of time like I
want to say ten seconds were hit the
door locked on his hand and he just
started swearing so loud I mean I made
my brother cry was very I mean that's an
understandable reason to swear yes go
people like it definitely happened to me
before
the fun in the funniest sue is the same
hand earlier that weekend he he was
breaking firewood and caught it like
sliced it open or bandaged up already
whoa sad day for that hands full
recovery he's fine okay thank you
oh no no I don't have any boost to get
back there okay good question from
Johnny in the chat have you I'd rush
very similar and tone to this game I
have not played on rush mediator Rob
rush on rush on rush Oh on rush
I played a little bit of it I think
that's the one where you just kind of go
around a track and blow each other up or
it's like no played it that much though
oh man you blocked me who got a shot
ma'am this is a oh my gosh we got some
donations guys hey we've got some
donations to blacklivesmatter from david
Trang's he gave $5 thank you David and
Sebastian Rams he gave $25 thank you so
much Sebastian that's awesome
Sebastian's watching she's watching both
so much
Sebastian is our editor-in-chief son oh
that's awesome
oh my bad oh you're good you're good
nope okay luckily they're not really
good we're good I like this zero zero
saying there is we're doing let's just
keep that way we're trying to get at
least one goal yeah this might just go
into overtime here good practice yeah
okay
don't let me score two more donations
this time for Cova Direct Relief Eric
Tay our very own gave us 12 dollars and
18 cents and he said we want to see that
face paint and magic markers yes all
guys anonymous donated $50 100 but then
they also said Psyduck is okay but
Gengar will always be best pokemon i
can't believe I had to read that on
stream and it breaks my heart right in
front of my own son but that's okay
because you don't need to thank you so
much for the donation man I start up you
doing great we're all doing great we're
doing awesome it's a team effort
I know it's like I need new nice oh you
got it you got it I kind of just like
tapped it as a baby tap damn that was
that was sick it was they loved it we
had a perfect perfect game I got a
pigeon head Oh should we switch car
again yeah let's try it which one it's
time I don't know I don't know we
shouldn't have not tried yet there's the
Rick that was really funny I don't play
the troll no I don't know I like the
Rick yeah let's do the record he's loved
Rick and Morty though I know mr.
meeseeks just like Oh Sebastian you're
so right he said no Psyduck is the best
that's so true I appreciate that so
we're at a hundred and fifty two dollars
in eighteen cents in donations so we're
getting closer to our stretch goal here
yeah yeah so if you tuned in late the
stretch goal is when we hit two hundred
dollars in the stream Naomi's gonna do
some face painting and we're gonna give
you some options as to what she's going
to paint on her face and then Rob
without a mirror is going to trying to
copy the same thing on his face with
some markers sewing it'll look identical
if you part of that I'm identical I'm
sure yes
his will be pure art so we are currently
47 dollars anyway away from that goal
I'm dipping my paintbrushes in the water
getting their daddy alright hello $47 82
cents left donate to those links in the
description below and Ritchie's dropping
them in the chat as well and I will also
drop them in the chat on twitch thank
you to everyone who's donated sofar yeah
huge thank you big virtual hug big
virtual hugs here I love about this car
sounds just like like a grass grass
cutter I wouldn't say a lot of machine a
lot more machines I wear my puppy I have
a really good excuse now for my
scatterbrain it's true though love it
can't other news I don't have reason
uppy when did you get the puppy
we got like maybe four days ago like
it's a bit old yeah so definitely no
sleep right now you'll sleep right now
and he's nine weeks old so I really like
this comment and YouTube chat from Roja
he says do a ceiling shot flip reset
triple touch goal yeah I've done that
I've done that so many times I can do
that yeah yeah I got that like the back
I know that like the back of my house
every not before I go to bed every day I
denied the match I totally gave that to
bacon guy Danny's car looks like bacon
200 on broom he's like me with the theme
curse yes I'll give you that but
everything else at everything you else
you do I don't like so oh why am I going
that way who saved us
I thought you were passing it I was good
to me
[Laughter]
that's cuz of me I tried to block that
in and failed like a you know miss like
a mr. meeseeks just failing meeseeks
can't help what's his name with his is
one simple wish of having to improve his
game by two points or something no Jerry
Jerry I just saw that episode recently
so that's how cut that's how come it's
close in my mind it's close enough
yeah I just watched all of season four
it was pretty good I think what the
latter half was pretty good had some
good episodes about a Mehsud episode it
was funny
it's a retraining yeah um I'm not fully
finished the season but I love
everything you're doing yeah no
complaints nice or your sheep happy
stress rats which is such a old man
thing to say bacon guy tasty make say
what a wholesome stream and there there
are requests to see your puppy can we
see the puppy on stream maybe at when we
reached it 200 yeah when I'm doing I can
nice leverage still made donations now
guys wants a hundred bucks each you were
good really cute puppy too so yeah I
don't know where he's at in his cycle
he's got this like every 1/2 hour
it's just snap snap yeah and then around
run around do his little business and
then play like create like just bite
everything and then play with everything
and then and then eat a bit of food and
drink some water and then back to bed
mm-hmm and that's just every every hour
and a half I say that's just fog like
Clarke [ __ ] you
that's the puppy life it's a good life
it is a good life does eat a lot of food
and used to get hungry what was the
question
Oh how much food does he eat and he was
a hungry boy he's not that hungry he
likes he just likes playing and called
just munch it's about like a cup of food
today it's not that much little guy but
I'm sure that's gonna change like he's
yes he's gonna grow and it's pretty soon
as little poops will be big food we got
a donation we have a $20 donation from
it was probably fork ovid Direct Relief
thank you so much for your donation you
want to be cool like that
links are in the description below we're
only 27 dollars and 82 cents away from
the stretch goal of some face painting
and a puppy guys I want to see the puppy
so please get I think we need I can get
the puppy in here guys I'm bargaining
here it's a two-for-one deal yeah
exactly
thank you cents more and we're getting a
new puppy so worth it come on yes no
there's more on orange right yeah I
don't know why it's not for some reason
it flipped but yeah we're uh I thought I
thought for some reason that we oh great
I hate these
oh you got our whoo that was a nice
though some nice air bro what's a good
master Oh one minute remaining I'm
setting it up I don't Oh
he blocked it it's okay I really just I
just love this game even if I lose it's
a fun game that's so fun
Alexander Alfaro said yeah it's the
yummy DCC how are we how close are we to
the goal we are twenty seven dollars and
82 cents away not that much not very
funny minute we're gonna hit it need
some boosts gamau haha thanks that was
perfect
exactly what I was hoping yeah that was
beautiful that was beautiful from the
moment you had the ball nice okay so we
just need three goals and yeah yes thank
you it was probably me and the twitch
chat for donating oh you donated to the
LM as well I'm gonna check that also
yeah they're calling defense we
definitely needed some defense on that
one oh my god eight seconds I'm going
for it yeah okay
the right the rig did not help help
cause yeah definitely the rig
[Laughter]
let's change it up yeah I guess let's
just do it every time let's just try a
different card yeah let's try it out
look down for any votes yeah it was
probably me do you have a vote on the
car that Naomi uses I'm gonna put the
names in the chat for you right since
you donated to both causes thank you so
much I was uh speaking of Rick and Morty
I my buddy oddly enough last night was
like saying he just started watching it
he's never heard of it I showed him I
think my favorite episode is the one
where they just have like
interdimensional commercials throughout
the whole thing oh my gosh yes oh my god
the one is they like actually I think
yeah yeah they like actually do improv
the one is that the two brothers won in
a world yeah are you hearing laughs in
the end because he's just like
stuttering as he goes it and and the
women with cat cat tomato guns the
beginning is the best like in theaters
now coming this summer which it was
probably me mode like electric which
love it let's do it such a nice guy
so like bright and fun expert how close
are we
it was probably me donated $25 to BLM
and there's a delay on it updating but
that means we are only two dollars and
82 cents away few cents away guys
someone gives 282 even if you each give
food we're like oh we're okay I'm ready
to play okay do it we got the electric
which what's your color you're called
your car cards I think start to Kumi
Takumi Takumi I can change
I'll trade records why not oh yeah do it
oh we got it anonymous no let me let me
read these donations really quick
anonymous donated 1782 to Cova direct
relief and anonymous donated these are
two different anonymous is $20 and said
five dollars for every goal Naomi scores
so thanks for that $20 some goals yeah
thank you so we made it we made it to
our straight oh sorry this is the time
Naomi's gonna do some face painting so
let me put some options in the chat and
then yeah so here are some options also
puppy hello and you get to see the puppy
yeah let's I'm gonna text Kyle now to
get him into the room since he's on a
puppy Duty yeah good alright in the chat
please vote for what you want for face
painting we've got flower puppy rainbow
themes of her car's Batman logo those
are just some options you can throw out
some suggestions if you want but
probably lead with one of the options
that we have here I love that coat for
what you want and any we're gonna see
the puppy I can't wait for you guys to
meet so Odin is his name and of course
God of War reference but also we
nicknamed him Odie sometimes which I
said by the way he's like OD for short
okay I just want to clarify it was a
joke he is the same
and number of letters as Odin yeah so
you guys could can say hi to Odin and
yeah you should be coming in any second
now
I think Kyle's Oh Kyle's in a meeting
right now so I might have to go get him
or we could wait to have him show up a
little later
yeah later we could do the face painting
first okay cuz I think at 1:30 yeah I
think it'll be free so see the puppy at
1:30 and we'll do the face knitting
first yeah
don't worry there shall be puppies so
we've got one vote for puppy we've got
two votes for Batman logo one vote for
GameSpot logo and then one vote for
themes of her cars another roof for
Batman logo that's winning so far all
right
it's Batman logo as an option selfishly
so I succeeded all right let's get this
done Batman logo
you got your markers ready Rob Rob's
gonna try to copy I guess okay I'm gonna
put this one on my cheek my left cheek
for for now um let's do it yeah let's do
it I'm here so this is gonna be real
fast waiting no we don't mind waiting
all right Robin gonna freehand a a
Batman logo on your face right now I'm
keeping an eye on these donations please
support them and their art right now by
donating to KO vid 19 direkt relief and
two black lives matter those links are
in the description below we're gonna do
some face painting and some drawing on
Rob's face with some markers right now
and you don't have a mirror
he's just going for it like a beautiful
table mirror like this
I do Animal Crossing I'll just be
watching this stream and
and following delayed all right got our
little bad head alright looks like a
heart I did have to pull up an image I'm
a little embarrassed that's totally fine
that's one make sure I get it right this
is almost like a game of telephone I'm
gonna cover my pair myself you're doing
great so we know we can reveal you yeah
yeah do that
yeah yeah but let's go to Naomi and then
we'll reveal Rob I take off my glasses
so we have confirmation
Odin is man yours on his way yeah hey
we're gonna be nice nificantly yeah
we're gonna bless with puppy and uh oh
my gosh look at this baby that is that
is the cutest puppy weeks old nine weeks
old my friends Wow
oh I know he's but he's gonna try to
lick my face here Batman logo but he's
gonna hang out in the room so thanks for
joining us Odin yeah from a nap oh my
gosh like what's this paint this peanut
smell he's gotten really good smell like
a smelling ability I guess he's he's
very like I'll pull out his little
treats and they're like you know six
feet away maybe farther and he's uh he's
like he just freaks out he's like I
smell it where is it
and he's like looking around
[Laughter]
they're another piggy on ya
what Street uh so I don't know what they
are called but they're these little like
round tasty treats like I think they're
they're flate they're beef flavored and
they're hopefully there to help him
train like his you know potty training
and make sure he he gets rewarded when
he does good stuff
you're so well-behaved so well-behaved
boy have fans in the chat Dale said
puppy power
Zhou Bo said so freaking cute Sebastian
said aw vitamins that adorbs in Lhasa oh
he's so cute
so did when you put from cuteness he's
so cute
you're being so calm usually it doesn't
like being picked up or he'll a cert
whining a little bit but it's being good
for the stream yeah thanks Odin we're
gonna put you down now it's so I got
distracted by the dog yes me too I was
like going over there
no and I I think I should I should have
kept going so now I don't know because
I'm not myself so I don't know where I
started I got use your phone like I
should have nobody
oh yeah his face cam put your phone in
selfie mode I mean it's for a starting
point just to center yourself and then
keep drawing without the phone I love
that's resourceful that's that's smart I
don't know why I keep getting a call
from California I bet it's a very I
think it's I'm just gonna get a sharpie
oh are you kidding it's too washable
snowbank it's so faint it's it doesn't
work on skin as long as you have
something in the house to help you
remove the sharpie like do you have a
toner I have a whole kit
you know I'll just use it I'll just do
some fuel otherwise you have to walk
around the dome working from home as I
got no one to I will go get a Sharpie
beer bags alright alright I believe he's
gonna start be his face I can't believe
it guys are doing this I'll bring this
for you it's for charity it's for
charity luckily we yeah it's gonna take
a long time to get Sharpie out I guess
the good news is we're all working from
home and we yes I hope he doesn't have
any meetings today
yeah like gonna zoom meeting and try to
explain away well his face is just for
charity okay so I kind of messed up the
little pointy leg looks pretty good but
it works right good yes not perfect uh I
like it I think it looks really good
yeah Oh Eric tag it was two dollars and
18 cents and said my small donation for
Odin cam cam
okay Odin stop chewing away loves cables
he just wants the cables and I'm like
you can chew on your chew toy which
tastes like dick but he doesn't want to
you just want cables I don't know cool
so the next stretch goal will be should
we do 150 after this since we've reached
the first one yeah let's do that
okay so when we reach the next 150 after
200 so no permanent marker let's switch
back the cameras Eric no not yet you're
sacrificing a lot it's literally gonna
look like crap like
it's for charity guys I'm so sad that
that stores don't have it's hard to find
face pain I feel like it is it is hard
right now yeah that that CVS clerk
really screwed me over
alright this is gonna look like crap
there's not if I mean do you like water
paint or i i'm already invested it's
it's re avenue what give me another
second okay I do have meetings today
crap do you want to stop I'm ready and
I'm gonna get the reveal really late on
the stream because I'm looking at that
feed all right go for it there it is
show it yeah let's let's get a little
puppy cam in the Odin cam you're not
trying to steal your thunder or anything
but that's that's pretty good
it looks like a Batman outline I guess
sharpies don't work on skin very well
either
I thought for sure that would work cuz I
used to use okay full disclosure when I
was a kid though
I used to use up washable markers for
like tattoos charge people 25 cents for
them and you were drawn on people but
maybe you could draw on your arm if that
might be a little bit better maybe yeah
try that no I I'll be right back guys
got it by Odin Oh
so if you want to donate towards the
next stretch goal where Naomi's going to
do more face fainting we're gonna go for
the next 150 and that will be the next
stretch goal so we are at 237 dollars
and 18 cents right now coming yeah you
see that hitting the first one yes thank
you for helping us reach our for a
stretch goal all right all right
best coming together I believe so we'll
have to keep it simple for the next one
like let's just do it
Eileen bass man okay I guess I'm not I'm
just not pressing down hard enough for
something I don't I took not like you
just have such like silky smooth skin it
just doesn't I'm done with that one all
right
okay like it's not come on washable
marker I actually shot I think it would
let's just try your arm like I think
it's a bit more like the skin's a little
less smooth back into rock and wig Jana
hop back into a game my electric which
here has been jonesing for some let's
get back to rock it League yeah what
it's worth it's almost the same as what
I have I should have spent last night
not playing rocket League but face
magnets all right we're jumping back
into rocket League if you want to donate
towards the next stretch goal of more
face painting Naomi that's we're $112
away from that so please donate using
the links in the description below and
also in the chat I love it
thank you to everyone who's donated
already thanks for hanging out with us
and if you can't donate then just share
the links oh I joined failed key try
again
uh you're still in the party right yeah
okay it's I guess did you try to start a
match it just a pop the screen popped up
to say about it minefield should be good
yeah we're searchin Oh where's you gonna
change your car oh yeah oh yeah all
right I'm gonna I'm gonna do this oh
well I'm gonna Ram it I'm gonna
randomize and you you guys do you guys
told me when to stop okay
again probably not me right only shot
it's a bit of a delay with chat about
yeah okay I can I can wait I guess no
unless it's gonna take too long what if
it you guys just will pick yeah you got
pick that's cool
look at that look at that yeah it's
pretty cool should I go again oh we hit
the money yeah yes like iteration for
that one
do tell you know I it's it's what I call
a case of the Mondays just putting on
your devil horns and yeah yeah I don't
know what community flag that is is that
does anyone know what that is okay but
not because it's a different color um I
don't know it's got a heart in the
middle it looks like an eagle anyone in
chat knows butoh still yeah here we go
there we go it's in it face paints on
the mark
yeah I hate when the carton them all is
right above your head like how do you
mean I've done oh no that was me that
was my fault dang it he just completely
with it I feel bad it blew you up no bro
I need you back oh oh thank god thank
God you were there oh I got them typing
see this is the site you do it out okay
this is this is the this is the real
game here is you just kind of like hey
you got a fake talk smack I told him not
to hit my car and now I guess he wasn't
are you there can you get it they're
pushing their aggressive been so slow
just like the balls
slowly roll guys run and bam nice
my car is expensive oh yeah
so mindless I was not even I would get
that look at that look at it
we're just playing so it must be the
face paint yeah we've given us powers
freakin nice Steve yeah okay good
set it up here or something I don't know
let's see what happens
oh that might be a set for you know they
they've got it
they've got it on lockdown oh crap oh I
didn't think that was gonna happen
you guys got this yeah we do
I got it
I sound like car sounds like my real
life car my Ford Explorer I'm driving
around oh my god that was so mean that
was so mean yes only we're not watching
that replay that's from damn Chanel
Wayne said naomi is good at this at
streaming yeah yeah I appreciate it
activity that was after you alright I
not step it up or anymore anymore
sharpie
it's like they probably were just
letting us get a couple goals they're
like wait let's style on him no ah nice
nice got it no it's not gonna go in so
aggressive I appreciate that though cuz
it's like that's really what you're
supposed to do and I'm just like I'm
just kidding it's a little tricky I
couldn't go back in time skip that Thank
You Hans Alfonso we're just giving them
a little hope that's what we're doing
oh my god we're doing is very calculated
exactly
yeah okay that's good well I don't know
what I did but I hit it with my scarf do
you prefer the the lock on the ball mode
or do you usually go I I swap between
the two I'm not really I'm like I need
something that's just oh yeah that's
fair I know people do that for sure I um
I just feel like that with a camera lock
and like you can't see everything around
me sometimes there's anything to watch
out for
you know what more yep we're like more
often not I use it I don't turn it off
to like get boosts cuz I can't see where
boost is or something like that yeah
did you want us to replay that do you
want us to replay your goals I mean I
just Poli said II missed that one I
really know I was really bad on my part
guys nations yay
[Music]
anonymous donated $15 and said let's
show Marvel some love and get the
Avengers symbol on the other cheek and
we've got a vitamin bp1 donated $40 and
said in honor of Odin /od
oh thank you and I'm sure Odin
appreciates the love oh yeah for sure
little does he know he's already helping
save the world yes yeah oh that guy
straight booted me out of the way I did
not like that that was bad stop it's
okay we're still we're giving them a run
it's all good well go for it
ah yeah see ok this time I had to look
behind me nice get it heard I'm gonna
try just to blow them up or distract
them get it in let me get out of this
freaking goal no no what sometimes just
wasting so much time trying to get back
like get my car back in order no punch
it well played GG well played Yugi seven
dollars away from the next goal of more
face paintings right there we've got ya
those nations are good hands
yeah 57 dollars away and then we'll do
more face painting and we've got 40
minutes left in the stream so let's make
that happen those donation links are in
the description and in the chat so thank
you guys so much for your donation so
far and for hanging out with us today
yeah I've got any questions for Naomi
just ask him a chat and they'll ask her
for you
perfect all right new car let's do I
like your cars were matching like their
dead mouse oh nice let's do uh well
Stewart our Downton Abbey yeah I'll just
talk British the whole time Rock and
Abbey
oh yeah I want to do a British accent I
won't put you guys through that
I'll just I'll just laughs ferry oh my
goodness oh you have a matching hat are
you I think this works like Sherlock
Holmes satyrs here this is incredible
it's great you like Holmes and Watson
next time we play this we have to do
like like we match all our themes like
everywhere we just said like a dynamic
like obviously Robin oh yeah you could
do there's actually a Batmobile Robin
what it righto he had a bike there right
for at least at least in the in the
movie which one was Batman Forever
or Batman Robin oh my god you might have
got that in color rather than brown so
my car shoots the passion of love nice
[Laughter]
boost that is the strategy sometimes
they they just get all the booths so you
can do yeah definitely
hey question from our last donator of
vitamin D Kia one asked Naomi what breed
is breed of dog is Odin Oh French
Bulldog I was just so close it was
supposed to go oh yeah yeah you got it
oh it was in my way well good to good
defense
oh you missed it it's mine
thunder bro yeah go run it yeah that's
good
oh yeah Aubry back hard on the bring
back but just ask or just just get it
goal we got we got another donation from
anonymous $20
it says Rob needs more make up for his
big meeting today break out the sharpie
oh yeah which brings us to what we are
37 dollars away from my next goal so
close
thank you so much dollar I mean what up
I want to I'm trying to think if I have
anything else in the house that like
better give me five bucks per goal is
still there did it making me get through
this it's helping to get through this
okay I'm going for it
I wasn't straight on the hit there so
the car that Mel went the other way
oh my god no that was that was why okay
I never usually miss when it's uh when I
go for it so I don't know what's going
on wanting you if you donate up to the
stretch goal hole you know more owed in
time 38 more dollars not that much yes
don't that what does name giraffe panic
draft that was really close oh that was
nice you know I feel like I play better
when I'm not even trying hard you know
that thing like this the Chi yeah
universe mm-hmm
lose your body lose your mind we need to
get this draft guy off the court get him
out of here okay he's doing the defense
thing and I know that we should probably
do the same but it's not even air I had
like three shots I didn't even know
drafts could play rocket League that
sounds really difficult cause like
you're so far from the ball I was more I
was were thinking of like the hooves of
a okay
don't touch anything we need to see that
guy's Eric J gave us more money $24 and
he wrote hot dogs get you hot dogs Rob
cat also you're our hero
nice good job that was their best game
yet yeah how's it going that was good
that was really good we're only $13 away
1386 $13 that's a gimme 1982 Matt will
pay more puppy yeah how often have you
put spent 13 bucks at Chipotle
exactly
oh it's thinking us a sandwich was like
what's a good sandwich is 13 any
sandwich around our work at 1 second
Street in SF Naomi knows she used to
have to pay those prices yes yes I did
though should we do another mattress we
go back out to the lobby
are you left no you're good Barbie girl
we haven't done we haven't done the
troll we haven't control boho we haven't
done yet I think we should do boho let's
do it oh man but you're I know sure
dardo shock man Wow
vitamin B P 1 donated again $38 we made
it
for more opened item I mean more Odent
on them yeah let's do it
so more Arden time and put it in the
request ask and you shall receive
I'm dropping a slack bring up the boy
boy let's see hydro donated $5 for
Naomi's goal thank you thank you alright
got my paintbrushes so we're not getting
into this match right we're just gonna
okay face painting
what do we want at least eight alright
so I'm gonna drop some more options and
we're gonna include that Avengers logo
that someone donated for as an option
okay okay so we've got flower poppy a
rainbow one of the car themes and
Avengers logo pick one good options I
like it and so on put up I'm gonna put
on my forehead I think alright and I
were jealous in the toilet yeah we're
heads good it's it out with please vote
in the chat for what you want painted a
flower a puppy a rainbow one of the car
themes or the Avengers logo as suggested
by one of our donators and I will check
on these donations one more time oh
we've got another $38 from David Trang
thank you so much for black lives matter
thank you so much David
Oh didn't says thank you Odin says thank
much very he says thank you
[Laughter]
he's got the load in camp well-behaved
oh my hey I think I can see there's guys
he did his poopins
oh he's so uh yeah I think he can I can
think you can grab him
thank you for hopping on the stream
Thanks odin's you're welcome all right
we got three votes for Avengers so I
think we have an Avengers logo coming
okay we've got a Marvel DC crossover on
new me right now love it love it okay
it's so big a big a with an arrow what
is that yeah it looks like an a arrow
inside a circle mm-hmm okay mm-hmm it's
uh should we do a gold one it's usually
gold I think any colors red red red eh
yeah sometimes it's red sometimes it's
white sometimes it's black oh so it's
never gold I'm just talking out of my
surrounding like the surrounding circle
of it is gold I think the first one that
popped up was like a gold it could be
gold yeah yeah but it's it's all good
let's do red limit depends on what
season it is like whether it's
spring/summer and thank you guys so much
for all your donations we really
appreciate you helping us raise money
for black lives matter and cover 19
Direct Relief you guys are awesome and
thanks just for hanging out with us
today
I appreciate it yeah so Naomi's gonna
work on her Avengers logo going on the
other cheek and now both Marvel and DC
yeah Jaime let's hide Rob and show Naomi
and her progress okay I got I got red
here let's see how it goes good
yeah smelly may be fused baby powder on
your face do you baby powder hmm I don't
have babies I know something that would
help create like a can't or like a
primer like yeah like this the paint
color can latch onto mm-hmm I feel like
that's the problem we're running into
you
yeah I agree what's right hey it's
coming to life here the the date the a
has a longer leg here down here it's
like this so just saying you know we
have already got four hundred and
seventeen dollars and 18 cents during
this stream thank you so much guys
thanks guys that really really is
awesome ah
oh we're saving the world heck yeah all
right here looking good looking good
looking good it's coming together uh now
we got a doer circle and then I'm gonna
use maybe like white or black to
highlight the arrow that's in the letter
a yeah I'm not gonna be able to do that
arrow yeah mine's like intermediate
almost pro level painting all right goes
here you know I just made this my excuse
to face painted a any excuse to face
paint I am on board I did once did a
pickle Rick face paint oh we don't have
to be if you were there when I did it
but I don't I don't remember that that's
I don't remember but it's probably
somewhere out there if you look it up
yeah
I also did the one was it the night king
from Eric Game of Thrones fry Jam oh
nice you guys could probably look that
one up yeah you're probably finding that
it was spooky looked weird
I do like make myself bold so you can't
see it right now but Rob is also
attempting the same thing with red on
his other cheek it's going so well is it
I'm gonna no you're using this is gonna
be better this is gonna be better I'm
using a variety I hope mixing washable
markers and permanent markers doesn't
create like something guys had to go to
the doctor
missing my meeting today good lord what
the hell's on your face how old are you
looks like you fell asleep and you were
babysitting a child with markers you
could say oh I'm a dad I was babysitting
okay yeah very nice need to do the or
arrow and then we're done
snot oh we did it focuses stuff I did I
tried outlining with gold and black
so we'll see what disaster yeah that
sounds challenging this is gonna look I
think I think I'd actually did a really
good job I think this is gonna be great
Oh Eric Andy right now huh it's it's
visible right Eric you can see it
what're these fees he asks if Rob's
meeting is with his boss we all want to
know its job it's with it's with the
team that I normally don't see on videos
should we review yeah I think I'm done
okay let's go back to the three shot
let's let's see Rob Whitney okay let's
go to Rob's one shot first I'm looking
there it is very proud of you
do I have something on my forehead I
didn't draw on my forehead my White's my
head I think he would
damn I mean we should probably get a
rating of whose is better right who wore
it best
it actually looks more like I got
punched in the face I don't know what it
looks like oh yeah it looks like a
gigantic you know bite Wow Whitney said
it looks so good but she first said oh
she said showing her support of course
Zack thank you guys for donating and
making this happen yeah and I know me it
looks really good this is a safe space
we can we can just be weird what you an
outline but I feel like it's gonna take
too much time it's gonna be fun
we have 20 more minutes it's true we
have 22 minutes left in the stream
Ritchie said looks like Rob is half
blushing I was a sloppy makeout session
accounts it's like it's like if someone
put lipstick on a dog try to talk trying
to make out with me I'm so glad you
decided to do this I should have gone
actual face paint I have like acrylic
yeah I have acrylic paint but I would
get real messy real quick yes I feel
like pretty bad for your skin I don't
know actually don't know and I'm I paint
I have like all those things oil paint
oil paints the worst you don't want to
put that on yeah yeah this outlines
taking forever and every time I'm just
scared to like mess it up you're doing
great there yeah well I'm giving that
arrow alright good
you should take it in my one shot yeah
go go to her one shot so they can see
clean there Hannah looks good oh so
close
okay there you go show it that looks
really good all right I'm almost done
I'm sorry I'm delaying this further
this is my art Oh
what is that that's perfect
side-by-side sick are we voting who's
voting who's voting for me that is
voting I'm selling them the vote you
guys need to vote for me my mind's a
masterpiece it looks mine looks so bad
vitamin and DCC both voted for Rami what
was the last cosplay you did um that's a
good question
the last one I did oh yeah I think the
last one I did was um I did Harley Quinn
bombshell oh yeah that was really good
that was awesome yeah all right now when
it's done it's a little messy but you
know that looks great it gives it a bit
of an edge I find another guy looks dope
Naomi you got three votes okay back to
rocket League we got ya minutes left in
the stream we can really good match dino
shock man could make me flag I think is
that you makin yeah
yeah your car looks sick sick brah like
are those cacti on top the room yeah
yeah cacti and succulents I love it
whoa I don't know maybe I clicked out
the window bags that's probably what
happened yep because I didn't have a
game sound so that explains the shape
I'm sorry oh you're good
we're back in we're back in oh yeah and
this one even has the oh yeah it's like
my hippie car basically cristela said
five dollars for every goal Naomi oh
okay great
I'm gonna keep I'm gonna try to do you
proud damn it these guys are good
they're like walking and stuff okay no
okay
okay
get some air toss gonna tossed it I
would have I would have saved us
that was that was all mean I was all for
it and okay I'm really missing these
usually I'm really good at them but the
would you call it face offs kickoff what
are they called if you're using a car
you're not using it leg to fish Shh when
a car kick we're gonna say yeah for this
oh my god I'm old nice super intentional
I can tell I'm just you know following
my own Chi you know the the universe the
universe is willing it uh it's going to
the flow just like slamming against the
backboard just like get out of here I
mean it's a strategy yeah definitely it
works anything to increase your
advantages yet look at that aerial shot
Oh
I'm messing it up that was all me Anna
can I die no no no all right good job
you got you say that yeah come on get
this out of here
come on yeah that was so good
look at how you did that you were just
like tap tap there a sec Park oh that
fits with my Dino theme yeah
Dino DNA that's like the next big things
like shark dinosaurs
where's my moves nature where's the
shirt yeah right I know sharks on a
plane
I know sharks no they don't do much
broader got a guy short movie oh is a
question in the twitch chat earlier what
movies are you looking forward to
Wonder Woman 1984 movie
if that comes out this year edge doing
Oh doing absolutely yeah sorry look at
the gas station
yeah Oh gonna do it oh good night
i I've watched that Wonder Woman trailer
like a thousand times that first one Oh
music that's that's half the reason
always I need to back dammit why do I
let them have the ball don't do that
yeah I know 13 minutes left in the
stream and we are still taking those
donations so please donate using the
links in the description below
and we're also dropping them in the chat
for black lives matter and Kobe 19 to
review go yeah yeah that was like that I
think I asked no mr. panic by screaming
[Music]
I'm going for it yeah you go do like do
it I was too late on that boost
yeah go I couldn't get any momentum to
go up there [ __ ] oh that might be up
just a inner bird set but that's cool
okay oh my god we're we do we got shot
we need that shot yes Dana watch it
watch this replay here see what I do
here check this out
coming in I know he's coming in look up
who I am now I should quit my job and go
proud
yeah I do a lot though but it could be
pro I think such a risk yeah oh shoot
you're right this is overtime overtime
okay sweat Oreo you go okay in those
situations cuz I'm very bad to scam I
lied earlier I'm not gonna go pro dang
it catch ow oh my god you got me eat my
catch ow okay yeah we are we're on 11
minutes outside think we could do
another match and I'm still watching for
those donations so thank you to everyone
who's donated and I'll let you know if
we get some new ones that come in I'm
doing Barbie girl yeah world uh-huh come
on Barbie let's go party at the
beginning of the song well bar me
I have I have two sisters I heard that
song a lot a lot music play music for
sure the other day yeah now now 15 or I
think they're on like now 108 or
something do you have a favorite Spice
Girls song Rob yeah I do it's um when
two becomes one that's a good one that's
one of the that's one there later hits I
think before they first album to become
one its first album first sound third
single I remember the music video I
remember it's like night and there's
chemistry like yeah they're all just
like slowly walk around turn from the
camera do you remember how it goes I
know I know the lyrics for sure come a
little bit closer baby and get it on and
get it on cuz it's the only way baby
let's play rocket League song wow we
change I don't know
a leopard unicorn Christmas or us being
like an old lady again I guess it's more
embarrassing that I wasn't trying to
[Laughter]
should we party again let's do it party
party maybe maybe this is the last game
for trying to do
oh yeah Kairi yeah that is my favorite
song from them I love that song I got
that song it's so good I also like like
I had a cart euros that was on DDR I
think yeah that was her other song um I
like I wanna dated in the desert oh I
don't know that videos iconic oh I
should have I should have told you what
I was doing there both had like the same
idea in mind is that so horribly you're
fine I just can't believe that didn't
happen I like I did who else
it is a glitch they could have gotten in
for sure well this is your it I can't I
know this I'm just like a granny here
driving my BAM
okay that's setup but grandma's driving
Oh
[Applause]
my guys name is so freakin long oh ok on
USS Enterprise oh it's a Star Trek
reference I'm here donation from
anonymous and they said more aqua my god
these guys if you're really great if the
other team could hear us
you're like that would have I feel like
that would drive them insane oh right
right past it come on
we got another donation from Richie 1069
Isis yeah thanks
[Laughter]
don't okay I always missed the air shots
and it's my fault
it's my bad oh oh yeah yeah come on oh
okay Richie for your donation would you
like to request any songs for mr. Robert
canler II to sing for you no more you
know what I just realized
Richie's doing highlights of this
[Laughter]
incredible beautiful
very good moments like yeah I want to
see those highlights for sure not and
it's not even of rocket leaves from our
rocket League stream $1.00 in 18 some
animus Thank You anonymous oh oh
all right here we go Oh
oh shoot I'm uh I'm screwing this up I
just wore it I really just did that
enterprises phone Rob Ritchie requests
you ought to know
how does it go again it's on the tip of
my tongue and I'm here to remind me I
don't know I don't know a fine Canadian
artist oh I know that's not yeah we were
talking about the office earlier today
with the karaoke that's okay Kevin Kevin
visit right he does a song you yeah I'm
gonna track there it's on yeah all right
all right
that's okay let's do this booze gun
boost
we're doing this
oh my god I wasn't prepared to save that
nice oh they're good they're good at
talking about oh they're really good you
guys good - playing really poorly it's
just that we're they're just they're so
good you know nice
that's yours but bump it Oh probably our
worst game and we have one minute left
on the three minute left but we'll place
to the end of this game okay let's just
get at least one more goal yeah I think
that's a good goal and then and then
that you know we'll call it a win yes
we'll call it away
Chris now Chris Ellis chat requests I
will donate $5 if they sing the boy is
mine does work for that goal but also Oh
God oh my god Meredith you that's one
you've redeemed us thank you
good job Rob totally redeem yourself
[Laughter]
can't wait to see the highlights of us
timing was impeccable $5.00 thank you
anonymous and they said can we get Rob
to sing a savage garden a lot of
requests for Rob to sing I don't think I
know I want to stand with you on a
mountain I wanna bathe you and see me
[Music]
guys we did all the cars you did it yeah
okay oh my gosh thank you guys so much
for all of your donations for helping us
raise money for black lives matter and
Cova 19 Direct Relief thank you to Naomi
for coming and joining us today thank
you for being a part of this thank you
rob for being a part of this and playing
rock it for all those goals for the face
painting and thank you to owning yeah we
have more streams for the next two weeks
so please tune in for more charity
streams at 12 p.m. Pacific time 3 p.m.
Eastern right here on gamespot
youtube.com slash gamesbut or twitch TV
slash games but come join us we've got a
lot of guests coming up in the next few
weeks for play for all
Naomi where can they find you yes you
find me on youtube at Naomi Kyle Twitter
at Naomi Kyle Instagram V Naomi Kyle and
yeah just hopping around all sorts of
places these days love it alright thank
you guys for watching and we'll see you
next time never make it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]